-The FDA is looking
at a new proposed rule
to ban menthol cigarettes.
Here to talk about it is
one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, in a segment
called "Is This Racist?"
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The FDA is going
to ban menthol cigarettes.
And that's ra--
Well...
I mean, it -- it is...
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
No, wait.
I mean, it feels ra--
[ Laughter ]
But is it, like,
all the way racist?
I...
Okay, okay, okay.
You've got to look at the --
Uhh...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, 'cause if I say that,
then that means the other thing,
so, dicey, dicey, dicey.
Uh, uh, okay.
Wait. I got it.
It is racist, because
the other cigarettes are --
Well, that's different.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Wait.
Okay.
Yeah, okay, wait, no.
Not racist.
Final answer.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.
-Wait, no!
I mean, maybe it is a little --
-We got a great show
for you tonight!